Lincoln town have just been promoted to
the Premier League but here are some of
the issues they're having to deal with
welcome to Oak Road now this is the
entrance for away fans come next season
thousands of fans who haven't been here
before are going to have to go through
these turn Styles and this entrance the
only problem is it runs straight through
these houses it means for people that
live in these houses they see those fans
walking through their Gardens and down
the stairs every single day when there
is a match on it means they get to hear
them when they're being particularly
loud and when they're celebrating but
also it means that the queues run all
the way down this road we've spoken to
lots of people who live on this road
some have lived here for over 20 years
most people are delighted they've been a
fan for such a long time others though
point to the sign of public disorder
they say when match days are on
sometimes there are crisp packets in
their front garden sometimes they have
to deal with lots of rubbish but also
even beer bottles being thrown into
their back Gardens too but this is a big
moment for this club and lots of
investment is going into it the question
is where will that money be spent